both loves kind of cheated on you then
yeah have you cheated
have you cheated um not on never
actually not or never what was what was
that answer
okay can we get some clarification
please
obviously no woman i've ever spoken to
has ever cheated apparently not anyone
that i've ever taken seriously and i
knew that they were taking me seriously
as well so like if i was like you know
hooking up with you like every so often
like obviously like
yeah but like like with the
you might have been exclusive
relationships
i want to say like you know we're
cheating
but when he's asking like have you ever
cheated on a man or your partner so i
don't have to fight like anything yeah
um has it been for someone you've been
in an active relationship with or you've
had that exclusivity conversation like
that agreement that's when you're saying
cheating like have you ever cheated on
anything no never there was never an
agreement where we were like oh
yeah so you've never never okay you've
never cheated never sorry that's proud
of you ever cheated
yeah of course no woman's ever cheated
it's never been done i feel like
whatever you commit like that's your
commitment you made like
no i'm just nothing
i'm just saying
the thing is when i speak right i speak
to guys and they say yeah there was
something that happened blah blah blah
but for some reason
women have a hard time admitting that
they've cheated
on someone
like if i've committed to you and i'd be
paid that but the thing is men and women
achieve at
similarly the same rate according to
statistics which is similarly this is
true it's true women get away with it
more than men but apparently no woman's
ever cheated
it's like what the hell is going on this
doesn't make sense
because i feel like with that i feel
like you know i'm not gonna defend women
but personally like if i've had that
agreement with you of exclusivity or
we've said like we're in a relationship
and we've had that conversation then
it's different like i haven't like
betrayed that
but it's different if we're not like in
an exclusive relationship and i can i'm
actually open i'm actually technically
single
because i can really do my own thing
right so you've never cheated on anybody
no ever no ever you'd have to be
boyfriend my girlfriend to cheat yeah
yeah of course yeah what happened to you
are you gonna have it like vocalized for
you guys to be not like just some kind
of agreement that you guys are have you
ever witnessed one of your girlfriends
cheating yes yes okay yeah
so those those are the ones that cheat
just not you right okay
eileen can vouch for me you were when i
was in a relationship i was doing
distance which would have been the
easiest to cheat did i did you ever see
me cheat talk to another guy
thank you thank you
and i was in a different country and i
was still loyal
can he say the same
so anyone here that wants to get up
pearly pearl you know where to hit her
up
send me an email
[Music]
i just think i think the whole cheating
thing is interesting i think men have
been
the the kind of dialogue is that men
cheat oh no women shoot too yeah women's
shoes i think nowadays like
they get cool men get caught i think
they're stupid with it let me be real i
feel like that's why i said women is
more made for like polyamorous
relationships yeah than men i think so
women are better at cheating themselves
i don't think i don't think men
are
stupid with it i think women just look
for it
women look yeah like i don't think it's
natural for a guy to go through a girl's
phone but i feel like we always be in
their
hold
phones
because you know what it is i feel like
that's where the whole woman gets
stereotyped as emotional beings we are
emotional but men are very emotional i
think they have a different way of
portraying that but there are men in the
world okay maybe i'm looking for an
exception but they're
do you feel like you're more emotional
than men generally
to an extent but no so
that's interesting i think i'm going to
be controlling my relationship that you
felt like that you were the guy
did you respect that man yeah
even though you felt like you were like
basically the guy in here yeah yeah
because it's like this like if i'm still
with you there was no reason for me to
think like no like i'm not going to
respond
sorry i don't think oh sorry thank god
god no i would say i don't think you can
say that
women are more emotional than women i
mean the men sorry i would say that we
have like we i think we said earlier
that we both
process and show it differently
and so i'd say our emotional
intelligence are basically the same it's
just the way that we show it in the way
that we express or react to it is very
very different
because things that hurt us will hurt us
but the way that you react to it is a
hundred percent different
so
but you don't think like we have
different hormones than men do so like
emotionally like we're a different
person every single day because because
like it depends where we are in our
cycle you already know you already know
a couple days before our period comes
don't mess with me
would your ex-boyfriend say the same
they would they would they would attach
hang on let me just try and clarify this
are you saying that as a woman
you are acknowledging
that
when you're coming your period you are
differently emotionally the days before
yeah oh my gosh hormonally yeah you
literally are
yeah i'll cry and i'm like why am i
crying all right all right so
if a man was to say
right so you've already acknowledged it
right so if so if a man wants to say
you know what you're coming your period
you're probably a little bit emotional
how would you respond to that well first
of all
when you say that obviously that would
piss the woman off yeah but hang on hang
on but hang on it doesn't make any sense
because you've already acknowledged it
well yes you already know you've
acknowledged the fact that you are
different when you're coming in your
period
but hang on when a man acknowledges it
and says to you uh you know what you're
coming period a little bit why is it why
is it going to piss you off because he's
telling the truth i think because you're
asking this question you already kind of
know the answer i mean
come on
i'm just saying why get pissed off when
you already know my friend used to do
that to me
i agree with what he's saying so i feel
like it's all sort of how a man says it
like in what context that conversation
is in but it's true like if he's saying
like he acknowledges it say you were
also ignored as a woman like i go
through these like premenstrual uh mood
swings or post mental or even during
your menstrual cycle
like why is it crazy if the man says it
to you as a as ammo not even ammo not
ammo it's just an another
like as i think because
it kind of diminished it feel it
it makes them feel like you're
diminishing what they feel when you